bonjour guerche better bouche merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous sur rt france
quelle est la situation de ces
populations indigènes sont elles
touchées par le virus
et dans quel pays particulièrement ils
sont malheureusement touché par le virus
si vous parlez des peuples indigènes
d'amazonie
on est très inquiet pour le brésil mais
pas seulement si vous parlez des peuples
aussi indigènes des natifs amérindiens
d'amérique du nord ont le peuple navajo
est actuellement décimé par la pandémie
donc là oui il ya vraiment en état d'
alerte particulièrement dans les pays
amazoniens parce qu'ils sont comme vous
l'avez dit dans le reportage
complètement délaissés par leurs
dirigeants et hauts et au brésil la
situation est catastrophique on a vu
quelques images du chef indien raoni
pour lequel on lance une campagne dans
quelques jours oui en effet ils sont
actuellement pour la plupart ils sont
déjà en confinement et se confirmant
qu'ils ont dû faire dans l'urgence a
fait qu'ils n'ont pas eu le temps de se
ravitailler correctement et notamment
les les produits d'hygiène ou les
produits les produits sanitaires les
médicaments manquent donc en effet il
lance un appel au secours la koica le
chef raoni d'autres bientôt vont aussi
lancer des appels et on a besoin de
mobiliser au niveau international donc
ce sont des populations particulièrement
vulnérables parce qu'il n'y a pas de
nourriture par par l'âge également sont
elles des populations particulièrement à
risque ou pas oui ce sont des
populations très vulnérable parce que
comme vous le savez sans doute lors de
la conquête des amériques
on a amené les premiers explorateurs
camp qu'ils s'adorent ont amené des
virus qui ont pratiquement décimée on
parle de 95% des populations indigènes
qui ont été décimés à l'époque et ils
ont gardé malheureusement cette
vulnérabilité
d'ailleurs pour entrer dans les terres
indigènes il faut montrer patte blanche
normalement il faut faire une visite
médicale
donc oui ils sont très vulnérables aux
virus et actuellement donc cette
inquiétude
elle est concrétisé par le fait qu'il ya
déjà eu des morts et notamment à un très
jeune
nos mamies qui avec seulement 15 ans
donc on pense que normalement les virus
ne touche pas les personnes jeunes et là
un jeune de 15 ans il ya deux mamies une
terre qui a envahi par des chercheurs
d'or il y en a plus de vingt mille
actuellement donc l'inquiétude est
immense pour les exploitants miniers et
forestiers les illégaux profiterait du
confinement pour agir l'un selon eux en
toute impunité
c'est ce qui les expose particulièrement
la contagion politique il faut montrer
patte blanche pour pouvoir pénétrer dans
ces territoires
donc là ce n'est pas le cas
vraisemblablement malheureusement ce
sont des territoires immenses donc pour
les contrôler pour les protéger c'est
déjà difficile en temps normal quand
vous avez des gouvernements qui ne sont
pas pro indigène seulement qu'on puisse
dire qu'ils ont fragilisé leur structure
en ce qui concerne monsieur molson arrow
il a fragilisé toutes les structures
indigènes donc on parle de précarité
extrême donc on va pas compter sur le
gouvernement pour pouvoir surveiller qui
rentre au qui sort actuellement dans le
territoire yanomami il ya plus de vingt
mille chercheurs d'or est en effet ils
vont amener le virus donc là on a une
tragédie qui est sur le point d'arriver
donc cette alerte que lance le chef
raoni s'est pas seulement pour son
peuple c'est pour les peuples de
l'amazonie toute entière donc ce virus
pourrait décimer justement des
communautés entières c'est le cas
franchement c'est vraiment leur
inquiétude et je crois qu'elle n'est pas
sûr exagéré
oui on a vraiment un risque et on peut
parler aussi d'un risque immense pour
les peuples n'ont contacté vous savez
quand amazon il existe encore des noms
des peuples non contactés soit en
isolement volontaire soit qu'ils n'ont
jamais eu connaissance de notre
civilisation et eux sont encore beaucoup
plus vulnérables
le corona virus pourrait faire des
ravages et là on parle même de génocide
c'est un mot que je n'utilise pas mois
seulement et pas pas de façon exagérée
non plus c'est vraiment les lanceurs
dallaire du monde entier qui exclurait
les peuples indigènes parle vraiment de
risque de génocide
oui et même des tno si dense et le terme
qui a été employé par par l'un des chefs
indigènes que l'on a vu au moins 60
personnes 60% de cette forêt amazonienne
vous l'avez dit on se trouve sur le
territoire du brésil comment est-ce que
déjà le brésil n'a pas décrété de
confinement concrètement au brésil le
risque est plus accrue par rapport à
cette contagion pourquoi le
gouvernement n'agit pas et autoriserait
t-il de l'aide humanitaire pour pour ces
populations en provenance de l'étranger
d'ailleurs bon en ce qui concerne le
confinement vous l'avais dit au niveau
national n'a pas été décrété
les peuples indigènes eux mêmes l'ont
décrété et donc par exemple si je prends
exemple sur le peuple du cacique raoni
ils ont carrément coupé les routes aux
alentours de leur territoire pour ne pas
risquer d'être contaminés et donc le ils
pratiquent déjà un confinement strict et
si nous appellent au secours c'est
justement pour pouvoir maintenir ce
confinement et qu'on puisse acheminer
par les deux ou trois personnes qui sont
autorisés à rendre visite et qu'ils sont
dûment contrôlé quand puisse leur
acheminer tous les produits dont ils ont
besoin produits d'urgence on parler
d'alimentation aussi parce que ça pousse
ça peut surprendre certaines personnes
on parle de forêt amazonienne
mais quand vous avez une arrivée
soudaine de gens qui n'étaient pas au
village vous avez besoin de lignes de
pêche vous avez besoin d'alimentation
basique pour pouvoir nourrir tout le
monde en effet quelques hélicos cet
appel at il eu pour l'instant
écoutez on le lance aujourd'hui donc je
peux pas vraiment vous répondre il se
trouve que votre sujet coïncide
exactement au lancement de notre
campagne qu'on lance sur planète amazon
point d'orgue
donc je pourrais vous répondre dans
quelques jours mais on espère qu'il aura
un grand succès parce qu'on lance une
première opération pour le peuple kayapo
du chef raoni mais bien entendu
malheureusement cette crise étant amenée
à durer on va lancer par la suite
d'autres opérations
d'autres peuples avec lesquels on
collabore aussi merci beaucoup gerd
petter brouch d'avoir répondu à nos
questions sur rt france et donc le début
de cet appel
on espère évidemment qu'il qu'il sera
entendu merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions